[MUSIC PLAYING]
FISHER: Okay, welcome
to the final session.
We have three speakers.
This is another
current research topic,
so we'll be highlighting
three researchers from CSAIL.
We have Professor Erik
Demaine, Professor Daniela Rus,
and Professor Scott Aaronson.
Since we've just
come out of a break,
I want to remind you to
turn off your cell phones.
And with that, I'll
turn it over to Erik.
DEMAINE: Thanks.
So I'm Erik Demaine
and I study algorithms
and theoretical computer
science and pretty much anything
that's fun.
And in particular today,
I want to tell you
about the science of origami
and the art of origami,
and how they relate
through computer science.
So, origami starts
at least centuries,
possibly a millennia, ago.
And it used to be about
folding very simple things
like cranes, or maybe
a few cranes out
of one piece of material.
But these days, it's
about folding super
complicated 3D forms out of
one square of paper, no cuts.
Each of these is
one square of paper.
This piece took, I think,
over a year to fold.
Give you an idea.
Here's some examples.
The top three are
all by MIT graduates.
This was a challenge
to fold a sailboat.
You can fold a sailboat with
the sails open or closed,
or you can fold a sailboat being
attacked by a giant kraken,
all out of one square
of paper, no cuts.
That's the crease pattern,
if you want to try it out.
And this is all
made possible thanks
to algorithms and mathematics.
In particular, this
is one new approach
to designing origami,
called Origamizer.
It's free software.
You can all download it.
The input, you specify some
3D model you'd like to make,
like the Stanford bunny.
You get a crease pattern,
which you can put in a square,
fold it up, and you
get this 3D shape,
which is exactly your bunny.
It just takes about
10 hours to fold,
but extremely general
and powerful, and pushing
the limits of artistic origami.
You can apply it to
other materials, as well.
This is folding one sheet of
steel into that same bunny.
This also takes a few hours.
It got accelerated a little bit.
And you get that.
So one sheet of
material, you can
make any 3D surface you want.
So that was Tomohiro Tachi from
Tokyo, folding here at MIT.
And I wanted to give
you one example of how--
origami obviously has a lot
to do with art and sculpture,
and there's a lot of
interesting mathematics
and geometry in there
as well, and algorithms.
And I like to do both, and a
group of us like to do both.
And it's really fun to
work on the same project,
both from an
artistic perspective
and from a scientific
perspective.
I want to give you one example
of a project over the last 12
years, called
pleat-folding, that
has gone from art to math to art
to math to art to math to art
to math to art to math to art.
So.
And I had seven minutes.
So here's a very cool folding.
You should try it at home.
You take a square of paper,
fold concentric squares,
alternating mountain and valley.
The paper folds itself
into this saddle surface,
which for a long
time people believed
is a hyperbolic paraboloid.
More on that in a moment.
We started playing
around with this
from the artistic perspective.
We came up with
an algorithm that,
given a polyhedron
like a cube, tells you
how to join a whole bunch
of hyperbolic paraboloids
together to make
some 3D surface.
And so this generates sculptures
using mathematics as--
algorithms as a tool to
design new sculpture.
You can follow a
similar approach,
folding concentric circles
instead of squares.
Here you have to cut a little
hole out of the center.
You get another saddle surface.
Paper folds into
that automatically.
And so on the scientific
side, we wanted to know,
what is paper doing?
And so we built a simulator.
These are photographs
of real pieces of paper
and these are simulations.
So we're simulating
what's going on.
Here's an example of
folding concentric hexagons
and the simulation.
Basically the paper wants
to bend at the creases
and not bend anywhere else.
And this is the
natural equilibrium
that physics finds for you,
or we can find by simulation.
Now, once you have a virtual
model of a physical piece
of paper, you can make
a physical sculpture
of the virtual model of the
physical piece of paper.
So this is with
3D printed spheres
to make a 1-meter static
version of that pleated hexagon.
So that's back to the sculpture.
On the mathematics
side, we've been
folding hyperbolic paraboloids,
probably thousands of them,
over about a period of 10 years.
And people have
been folding them
since the late '20s
at the Bauhaus.
But it turns out it's
impossible to fold
a hyperbolic paraboloid.
If you take this crease pattern,
you cannot make anything,
it turns out.
This was quite a
surprise, because we've
made a lot of them and
it looked pretty good.
But some things that you think
that may exist in real life
really don't exist
mathematically.
It turns out what you need to
do is add extra creases in there
in order for this
thing to fold up,
and then you get a nice 3D
model and everything works out.
And so reality must be
cheating a little bit there.
Back to the art side.
These are some sculptures in
the permanent collection in MoMA
with my dad, Martin Demaine.
And these are based on
the concentric circle
idea, which does seem to exist.
So we've switched
mostly to curve creases.
It's a bit unusual
for the origami world.
Here, instead of
a single circle,
we actually joined
two circles together,
make a 720-degree loop.
And you get a lot of
really cool twists.
These are, again, this
natural equilibrium forms
of those pieces of paper.
On the more scientific side,
more on the architecture side,
we're trying to--
by making small changes
to the crease patterns,
we can get a lot of
control over what 3D shapes
result in the equilibrium form.
So the idea is you want
to build some pavilion,
you just print out a
sheet, make it self-fold,
and it pops into whatever
3D form you want.
Back on the sculpture side,
we've been playing lately
with combining several of
these concentric circle models
together, joining them at
just a couple of key points,
and you get even more control
over the 3D form that results.
Back on the math side-- some
alternating back and forth
here.
That's the point.
We study-- this is more of
a mathematical idealization,
but you know, it's
really tedious
to fold all of these pleats.
Is there some way that I
could fold mountain, valley,
mountain, valley,
mountain, valley, n of them
in less than n operations?
You know that if
you make n folds--
if you fold a piece of
paper in half n times,
you get two to the
n creases, but you
get some weird patterns
of mountains and valleys
that's not alternating.
And I really want alternating.
Turns out you can
get pretty close.
The n folds, you
can get about 1.33
to the n mountain-valley pleats,
and that's close to optimal.
It's kind of fun,
although not practical.
It's a fun
mathematical diversion.
This is one of our
latest sculptures
to appear at the Smithsonian.
David Huffman-- I
imagine most of you
have heard of David Huffman
in the context of codes.
Huffman codes are in every
MP3 player, every compression
device, every cell
phone, I guess.
And David Huffman was a
professor at MIT for a while.
But lesser known is that he
was one of the few pioneers
of curved-crease paper folding.
And he designed these
three models in particular.
Most people have
never seen them.
And we're working
with his family
to document all of his work
and try to reverse engineer,
figure out how he
designed these models.
They're figuring out what
his crease patterns were,
how he came up with
these crazy foldings,
because they're really awesome.
If you were at the banquet
last night, you saw this video.
Otherwise you can watch
it on our web page.
This is combining glass--
both my dad and I
are glassblowers--
with paper folding.
And this sort of
gives you an enclosure
that constrains how
these forms open up
and so you get more
control over the shape.
And one very recent project
is combining that paper
on the outside of glass, make
it a little more exciting.
So that's the sculpture site.
I think that's the end of
the little tour from art
to math to art to math to art
to math to art.
And we find this a really
powerful way to work,
because if we get stuck
solving a math problem,
we can just build a
sculpture to illustrate
why the math problem is hard.
And then often
we'll want to build
some sculpture-- you know,
wouldn't it be really cool
if we could build x?
And then, wait.
Does x exist?
Is it possible to build x?
And then we have to do
new mathematics in order
to figure out how to
build that sculpture.
So we get a lot more
productive because we
have to jump back
and-- or because we
have the flexibility
to jump back
and forth between these worlds.
I wanted to show
one more fun thing,
which you can play with at
home, at ErikDemaine.org/maze,
I think.
So this is a maze folder.
So if you want to fold this
three-dimensional maze,
that's the crease pattern.
Just print that out
and play around.
You can make whatever
maze you like here.
And you can also type in
your favorite message,
like "MIT 150 rocks."
And then there's
your crease pattern.
Start with a large
piece of paper,
I recommend, and you can do it.
I mean, it is really possible
to fold these things.
Here's a simple example,
just folding a 5-by-4 maze.
I would love to make
one big enough for a rat
to run around in and
see what happens.
And yeah, here's
one last sculpture.
This is a crease pattern
that has little marks on it.
And when you fold
it down, you get
simultaneously "yes" in
three dimensions and "no"
in two dimensions.
So I guess we're a little
conflicted about the meaning.
And that's it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
FISHER: Thank you, Erik.
Our next speaker is Daniela Rus.
There you go.
RUS: So Erik gave you
a wonderful survey
of these amazing objects that
he can make by hand, by folding.
Now, what if we could
take those hands away?
What if we can even imagine
these sheets making the shapes
that Erik has painfully folded
over a period of up to a year?
That would actually
take us to a stage
where we would be able
to have sheets that
would organize themselves
as objects that
would program their own shape.
And that is a step closer
to our dream of programming
more than just bits, to our
dream of programming matter.
So what would it take
to achieve this dream?
Well, two things.
On one hand, we have to
make better materials.
We have to make
smart materials--
that embedding them, actuation,
sensing, computation,
communication, and all the
electronics infrastructure
that would enable the
control of these sheets.
And on the other side, we need
the algorithmic and control
basis for achieving shapes.
So in my research
and in my group,
we have been actually
studying this problem.
We have created sheets that
have been inspired by origami.
And this was done in
collaboration with Erik.
And here you can see a
sheet that has creases.
Along each crease,
there is an actuator.
We also have connectors
and other electronics
infrastructure.
And this sheet is able to be
programmed in this example
in two different shapes.
One is the boat, the
other one is a plane.
The programs are
generated automatically,
using a suite of
planners that decide
when each actuator
on this sheet will
get to move and in connection
with what other actuators.
So there is our object.
Now you can do other objects.
You can do a whole suite
of functional objects
using origami inspiration.
In this example, you'll see an
origami worm that is made out
of a specific crease pattern.
And the little springs
on the body of the robot
are actually shape memory
alloy actuators that
enable this robot to function.
This robot was printed out
of a single sheet of paper
and it was done in a matter
of a couple of hours.
So-- let's see.
I'm having trouble
with technology here.
Making shapes or programming
shapes by origami
is just one way of envisioning
programmable matter.
More generally,
programmable matter
is achieved when a collection
of robotic modules that
are physically connected
have the ability
to self-organize themselves
as a functional object.
And this object could be a robot
designed for a specific task.
For example, a
snake-like robot, which
would be the optimal way
of traversing a tunnel;
or a slinky-like
robot, which would
be the optimal way
of climbing stairs;
or a functional
object, such as a dog
that might turn
into a couch when
you're done playing with it.
This idea takes us to the
vision of making machines that
have flexible architectures.
Machines that have the
ability to synthesize
a third hand or a second
head or an alligator,
according to whatever the
manipulation, the sensing,
or the task needs
of the user are.
And this is extremely
challenging and exciting.
The key to success
in this field is
designing bodies
that have the ability
to achieve this kind of
shape transformation,
but also the
algorithmic basis that
generates the control structure
for how the modules move.
And so this has been
extremely exciting to me,
but also deeply personal,
because I grew up
reading and dreaming about
the Barbapapas family.
Now, the Barbapapas family
is a family of blobs.
And these blobs can
change their shape
according to whatever the
task they have to do is.
So they can turn
into cutting tools
when their house is
invaded by a giant bean,
or they can turn into containers
for collecting things,
and even objects for cooking.
So to me, working on
programmable matter
is like achieving a childhood
dream of building objects
that can change shape
like the Barbapapas family
I used to dream about.
So there are other approaches
to creating programmable matter,
besides folding.
And another one I
wanted to explain today
is the idea of smart sand.
So now imagine I give you
a bag of smart particles,
also materials that embed
actuation, computation,
communication, and connection,
and you tell your bag,
make me a rabbit.
After the bag computes a little
bit, you reach in the bag
and you pull the rabbit out.
When you're done
playing with it,
you throw the modules
back in the bag.
They return to the collective
group for later use
for a different purpose.
And so we haven't
made smart sand yet,
but we have made some
smart rocks and the suite
of algorithms that
programs shapes
with these rocks, following
a sculpting-like process.
And in this video, you
can see our approach
to making shapes by smart rocks.
Each of the cubes in
this video is a computer.
Inside the computer there
is a switchable magnet,
which is on in one
configuration, off in another.
Each computer also has
point-to-point connections
and communication to neighbors.
And as the communication
system detects neighbors,
that has the ability of
triggering the connectors
on or off.
Now, once you have assembled
this block of virtual marble
or virtual particles, what you
can do is that tell this block,
make me a dog.
And the modules
talk to each other,
try to decide which one's in the
final shape, which one is not.
Eventually, the decision
process converges
and the robots can then
reprogram their connectors
to be off if the
modules are no longer
part of the final object.
So here's the dog you
can obtain by peeling off
the spare material.
So we have not achieved
smart sand yet,
but we have moved from smart
rocks to smart pebbles.
The smart pebbles are 1
centimeter in diameter,
very small computers.
And the key technology
that makes this work
is something we call the
electropermanent magnet.
And this is what we use
for program connections,
for communication, and
also for transmitting
power between neighbors.
It's the C component
in my picture.
So I have shown you several
examples of programming shape.
And there are some
wonderful applications
in this field besides making all
the exciting objects that Erik
has been able to do.
For instance, making
3D topological maps
so you know where there is
a hill on your bike ride,
or in general, making
on-demand tools and objects.
But the challenge is
going beyond shape.
The challenge is
imagining these computers
whose material properties
you might be able to program.
For example,
mechanical properties
like friction and strength,
and also optical properties.
Perhaps someday we will
be able to have computers
that will become our
invisible cloaks.
Ultimately, I think this
field will have a great impact
on manufacturing.
I imagine the
RoboKinko's of 2020,
where I go not to print a
poster, but to print a robot.
I tell them what my
robot payload is, perhaps
to carry a radon sensor.
I tell them what the
endurance of the robot
is, what the space
it has to work in is.
And a day later, I go
and I pick up my robot
and I pick up the programming
and user interface
environment for it.
The robot is
fabricated in layers,
following the same
process we have
seen either with the
self-folding sheets, where
we build these flat sheets
with embedded electronics that
have the ability
to self assemble,
or following some
subtraction-like process.
And ultimately, this new way
of thinking about computation
will have deep impact on what
we think about computation.
Ultimately, in the field
of programmable matter,
resources such as actuation,
sensing, internal state,
external state, become
first-class citizens
just like time and space.
And what we will need
is profound advances
in how we design
computers and how
we think about the theoretical
models of computation that
take all these
resources into account.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FISHER: Thank you, Daniela.
So our final speaker of the
session is Scott Aaronson.
And at the conclusion
of Scott's talk,
Victor will have some final
words to close the symposium.
AARONSON: Great.
Thank you.
So let me apologize in
advance for a lack of origami
in this talk.
There will be time travel
and quantum computers,
but it's really no match.
So Moore's Law, I mean,
you've all seen this.
The number of transistors
per chip, for example,
is doubled about
every two years.
You know, these days mostly
just because of the increasing
number of cores on a chip.
But this is clearly
something which
is one of the major
things driving
the progress of technology.
So raises the question, if we
extrapolate into the future,
you know, where is
this going to lead us?
So one obvious possibility,
which was, I think,
already alluded to in Daniela's
talk, is the robot uprising.
So, you know, Google may have
just become sentient, you know,
just instruct all
of the computers
to connect it to the internet
to enslave their owners
and so forth.
Okay, this is actually,
I think from at least
from a theoretical computer
scientist perspective,
one of the less
interesting things
that could happen in the future.
And why do I say that?
Well, because even a killer
robot, on the inside,
it's still fundamentally
just a Turing machine.
So a Turing machine is
this theoretical model
of computation laid down by
Alan Turing in the 1930s.
And it pretty much describes
the internal workings
of every computer, every
Mac, PC, iPhone, and so on,
that we have today.
And furthermore, we know
that Turing machines have
some fundamental limitations.
I mean, Turing started
that out showing
that they can't solve the
halting problem, for example,
but we believe that they have
even stronger limitations
than that.
So one of the most famous
is given by the conjecture
that P is not equal to NP.
Okay, so your P is basically
the class of all problems
that a Turing machine or let's
say a modern computer could
solve efficiently in
an amount of time that
increases polynomially with
the size of the problem.
NP stands for non-deterministic
polynomial time.
It's a dumb name,
but it's the class
of problems for which, if
someone gives you the answer,
then you can recognize
it efficiently.
And the question is,
are these classes equal?
All of our ordinary
experience with the world
would lead us to conjecture
that they're not.
In other words,
there are problems
where you can
recognize and answer
if someone shows it to
you, but nevertheless
finding the answer yourself
could be astronomically hard.
Famous example is, say,
the Hamilton cycle problem.
I give you a graph with
a bunch of connections
between vertices.
And the question
is, is there a way
to visit each
vertex exactly once?
Is there a path that does that?
If someone shows you the path,
then of course you can check,
okay, well, indeed I
guess there was one.
But if you don't know in
advance what the path is
and imagine that there were
thousands of vertices, well,
then trying all of the
possible paths one by one
would just take an
astronomical amount of time.
The sun would go
cold before you've
made a dent in the problem.
So this is a famous
example of what's
called an NP complete problem.
So if P is not equal to
NP, then actually there
can be no efficient algorithm
on any present-day computer
to solve this problem.
So this is one of the
greatest open problems,
I would say, in all of
mathematics and science.
You can see that, because it's
done a cameo on The Simpsons.
But you know, it raises--
so assuming we all believe
that P is not equal to NP,
raises for me an extremely
interesting question
that's driven a
lot of my research.
Which is, is there
any feasible way
to solve these problems, then,
just consistent with the laws
of physics?
Okay, so this is now not just a
mathematical question, but also
a question about what
types of computation
do the laws of physics permit?
So you can think of
some hypothetical things
that would certainly make
these problems tractable.
So let me run you through
some of my favorite examples.
First one is what I call
the relativity computer.
This was a very simple proposal.
You would just
start your computer
working on some very
hard problem, maybe an NP
complete one, for example.
Then you would leave
your computer on Earth.
You would board
a spaceship which
is traveling at very close
to the speed of light,
go on a journey.
You come back to Earth,
billions of years have passed.
Civilization is gone.
All your friends are
long dead, but you've
got the answer to your
computational problem, okay?
You can think it's
interesting to ask,
what is the problem with this
proposal, besides the fact
that all your friends are dead?
Well, actually the answer turns
out to be the amount of energy
that you would need to
accelerate to that close
to the speed of light.
If you want an
exponential speed-up,
it turns out you actually need
to accelerate to exponentially
close to [? C, ?] which
then implies that you need
an exponential amount
of energy, which
then implies that your spaceship
has to be exponentially large.
So you're still spending
exponential time.
You're just pushing it
to a different place.
And this is an
interesting example
of how when you
take all of what we
know about physics into
account, what looks like a way
to solve NP complete or other
intractable problems quickly
may actually vanish.
We see that again and again.
Another of my favorite examples
is what I call Zeno's computer.
This would be a computer that
does the first step in one
second, the second
step in half a second,
the third in a quarter second,
next in an eighth, and so on.
So after two seconds is done,
an infinite number of steps.
Okay, well, what's
the problem with this?
Why don't we build this?
Well, people actually do
more or less try this,
then they try to
overclock their chips.
But the problem when you do
that is that your chip may melt.
It may overheat.
And actually, the
faster you want
to overclock your chip, the
more energy you need to cool it.
And actually, if you try
to run your chip faster
than one clock cycle
per Planck time,
which is 10 to the
minus-43 seconds,
then no one knows exactly
what would happen.
But according to the best
current physical theories,
the best guess is that you would
need an amount of energy which
would exceed the so-called
Schwarzschild bound,
which then actually implies that
your computer would collapse
to a black hole.
So I like this as sort of
nature's way of telling you
that you can't do something.
Okay, another of my
favorite examples
is the time travel
computer, where
if we had closed
timelike curves,
then actually we could sort
of create a situation where,
just in order to avoid
a grandfather paradox,
or in order to avoid a
logical inconsistency,
nature would be forced
to solve some very
hard computational problem,
including, for example
an NP complete problem.
And a simple example
of this would
be if you went back in time
and told Shakespeare what
plays he was going to write,
and then he wrote them,
and so then you knew what
they were, and so on.
So somehow this
really hard problem
gets solved of writing
Hamlet, for example,
and yet no one
ever does the work.
So this would be a great
thing if we had it.
So actually, I even
wrote a paper about this
that John Watrous
is pinning down
exactly what you could do with
this closed timelike curve
computer.
It turns out to be P space,
which we believe is actually
somewhat larger class than NP.
Truly, don't tell
my tenure committee
that I wrote this
paper, actually.
But okay.
Some of them are probably here.
But all right.
So now, but I want
to move on and talk
about quantum computers.
This is something
that on its face
sounds almost as science
fiction-y as the other stuff
that I've talked about.
And yet, there are
experimental groups
all over the world
that have been and are
trying very hard to actually
build quantum computers.
So what is this?
Well, this is a computer,
a hypothesized machine,
that would exploit the
laws of quantum mechanics
to solve certain problems
dramatically faster than we
know how to solve them
with any existing computer.
And the reason it could do that
is that according to quantum
mechanics, the state
of a physical system,
say, of end bits, is
actually a superposition
over all of the
possible configurations
that those bits could be in.
Which means that to specify
the state so you have end
particles, you may actually
have to write down a vector
of two-to-the-n complex
numbers, one for every possible
configuration of the particles.
So according to
quantum mechanics,
which has been our
reigning physical theory
since the 1920s, the amount of
information in a simple system
is tremendous.
Can be much, much greater
than classical physics
would lead you to believe.
And so maybe we could
exploit that to solve
some hard problems.
In particular, Peter Shor, who's
in applied math here today,
showed that in principle,
a quantum computer
could efficiently
factor large integers.
Unfortunately, what
have we done today,
after groups all over the
world, including here at MIT,
have been working on
implementing quantum computers
using ion traps, nuclear
magnetic resonance,
other proposals,
what we've done today
after about 20 years of work,
is to verify using a quantum
computer that with
high probability
15 is equal to 3 times 5.
So just the last thing.
So some recent work with
my student, Alex Arkhipov,
we actually just this year
published a long paper,
which is about a new proposal
for a very rudimentary type
of quantum computer, which would
be built entirely out of what's
called passive optical
elements, like beam splitters.
So you would just
generate single photons,
pass them through beam
splitters, and then mirrors
and so forth, and
then you would measure
where the photons end up.
Do all of this very reliably.
But we don't require
any explicit interaction
or coupling between
pairs of photons.
We thereby bypass one of the
main technological problems
to building a quantum computer.
Now, we have no idea how
to factor numbers or break
cryptographic codes using
this type of quantum computer.
But the main point
of our paper is
to give evidence that even this
rudimentary type of computer
can solve some problem--
problem of sampling from
a certain probability
distribution that under
plausible conjectures
is intractable for any
classical computer.
And there are several
experimental groups
that are currently
trying to implement
this experiment, at least
with four or five photons.
So I'm looking forward
to seeing that.
Okay, so a summary.
So from a theoretical
standpoint,
modern computers are all
kind of the same slop.
They're all just
polynomial-time Turing machines.
Now, mathematically, we
can envision computers
that vastly exceed those.
And we just have to imagine
into existence a closed timelike
curve or whatever.
But using quantum computers,
we now think that actually,
even in the real physical
world, we could exceed
the capabilities of
polynomial-time Turing machines
by a little bit--
do some things
like factoring that
are intractable for any
present-day computer.
But actually realizing that
remains an enormous challenge.
And I hope that things
like linear optics
will help provide
a path toward that.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]